the royal family congratulates prince
harry and meghan markle on the birth of
their daughter lillabet
but a source is now telling e.t the
family still feels upset with the duke
and duchess of sussex following their
bombshell interview with oprah winfrey
in march
i think there is a desire on both parts
to move on from this family risk
the source explains that the royal
family made a coordinated public effort
to congratulate and offer harry and
megan well wishes on social media
after the birth of their baby lily but
the source adds that there are still
lingering feelings of disappointment and
anger after the couple's claims in their
explosive oprah interview
where they accused an unnamed member of
the royal family of expressing concern
about the potential color of their son
archie's skin
before he was born so the couple have
names their daughter
lily bert diana mount saturn windsor
which is quite a royal name megan and
harry welcome their daughter
lillabet lily diana mountbatten windsor
on friday
and gave her a name that sweetly honors
queen elizabeth ii
and the late princess diana in a
statement the couple explained that
lillabet
is harry's grandmother's family nickname
and diana was chosen to honor harry's
late mother
well these are two really significant
and important royal names
diana of course speaks for itself and
i've long heard that if
prince harry ever had a little girl he
was always going to honor his mother's
name
and give her diana as one of her names
but i think the greatest
surprise has been lily bert which
actually many people don't even know
is an affectionate nickname that was
given to the queen
when she was little she couldn't
pronounce elizabeth it came out lily
bette
when she was just two and it was such a
cute and lovely name it's stuck
and according to a statement from
buckingham palace the queen
prince charles and camilla and prince
william and kate middleton
are delighted by the news william and
kate also shared a message for the
couple
and their first child two-year-old son
archie on instagram
writing quote we are all delighted by
the happy news of the arrival of baby
lily congratulations to harry megan and
archie
we do understand that harry did ask his
grandmother
for her blessing that is protocol that
is traditional and certainly when it
comes to
the name lily bed i think absolutely
right that harry asked and of course the
queen would
would have been in a very difficult
position she couldn't very well have
said
no but i think the general feeling is
that she was quite surprised a little
bit taken back
charles and camilla followed with a
personal message of their own
tweeting quote congratulations to harry
megan and archie on the arrival of baby
lillabet diana
wishing them all well at this special
time prince harry's cousin princess
eugenie
also celebrated the milestone moment on
her insta story
writing congratulations dear cousins we
couldn't be happier for you all
well i think everyone's hope is that
this little baby is going to be
a rift healer um because this
family division has really gone on for a
very long time now it's well over a year
it's been many many months since charles
the queen indeed the cambridges have
seen archie
in the flesh and we know that there have
been some
really quite deep problems between harry
and william
difficulties between harry and his
father and i think it's everyone's
hope that this little baby will will be
a peace offering
in many ways and that she will help to
bring this divided family
back together meanwhile as harry and
megan enjoy the bliss
of baby number two e.t is also learning
more about the future of megan's career
as an
entertainer the source explains that the
39 year old actress has
no current plans to return to acting
adding that she is fulfilled with the
impactful work she and harry are doing
with their non-profit
archwell the source says that archwell
allows megan to quote
create content on positive public
discourse on the issues and ideals that
continue to drive the duke and duchess's
work the source adds that she's excited
about everything she and harry are
creating
and what the future has to offer for now
the source says megan is focused on
making a difference with archwell's work
[Music]